bonjour à tous bienvenue sur la chaîne
de vulgarisation des instances
politiques
la chaîne qui vous explique en quelques
minutes les détails des organismes
politiques français aujourd'hui on va
parler des décrets un décret c'est un
texte que l'on dit normatif donc c'est
un taxi fixe de nouveaux droits et
obligations ou qui modifient ce qui
existe déjà dans le groupe des textes
normatifs les décrets font partie de la
famille des textes réglementaires avant
d'expliquer ce que c'est un décret on va
faire un petit rappel parce c'est un peu
compliqué les lois dont on avait parlé
dans une précédente vidéo font aussi
partie de la grande famille des textes
normatifs français elles sont décrites
dans l'article 34 de la constitution
alors que les textes réglementaires eux
sont décrits dans l'article 37
les lois appartiennent au pouvoir
législatif est donc au parlement alors
que le pouvoir réglementaire lui
appartient à l'administration et au
pouvoir exécutif
c'est à dire le gouvernement et le
président de la république dans la
hiérarchie des normes les textes
réglementaires sont en dessous des lois
les autres textes réglementaires à part
les décrets sont les ordonnances les
arrêter et dans une certaine mesure les
circulaires mais vous l'avez compris
aujourd'hui on ne parle que des décrets
on verra des autres dans d'autres vidéos
donc les décrets ce sont des textes
réglementaires et ils sont pris par le
président ou par le premier ministre la
portée des décrets et variables ils
peuvent être réglementaire quand il pose
une règle générale qui s'applique à tout
le monde ou individuelles s'il concerne
une ou plusieurs personnes déterminées
la plupart du temps les décrets
réglementaires permettent d'apporter des
précisions et ces mesures d'application
énorme
c'est pour ça qu'on parle parfois de
décrets d'application on va prendre un
exemple pour être sûr de bien
différencier la loi de son ou ses
décrets la loi evin c'est la loi qui
pose les bases pour lutter contre
l'alcoolisme et le tabagisme a été votée
au parlement en 1991 cette loi ont
entraîné entre autres l'augmentation du
prix du tabac l'interdiction de fumer
dans les lieux publics comme les gares
ou les transports en commun
et l'interdiction de la publicité pour
le tabac plusieurs décrets sont venus la
compléter la précisé eon rendre cette
loi plus contraignante
par exemple un décret bien connu sur
cette loi et le décret du 15 novembre
2006 qui a permis de préciser
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics
ce décret rajoute à la loi
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
fermés et couverts accueillant du public
comme par exemple les restaurants et les
hôpitaux et ajoute l'interdiction totale
de fumer dans les écoles collèges lycées
ou tout autre établissement accueillant
des mineurs
c'est le parlement qui vérifie que les
décrets d'application sont bien mis en
place et de façon conforme
il existe aussi des décrets
réglementaires qui ne sont pas forcément
au riz à une loi on parle alors de
décret autonome par exemple les règles
qui concernent leur régime des
contraventions sont essentiellement
gérés par décret car ce n'est pas un
domaine qui appartient au domaine des
lois pour finir les décrets individuel
eux servent principalement à la
nomination de hauts fonctionnaires
il ya plusieurs types de décret dans
l'ordre hiérarchique on retrouve d'abord
sur dix ont délibéré en conseil des
ministres l'aube alma les décrets qui
sont pris en conseil des ministres sont
ceux qui sont relatifs à des thèses de
loi importants par exemple l'état de
siège doit être décrété en conseil des
ministres
certains hauts fonctionnaires comme les
ambassades sont eux aussi nommé par
décret de délibéré en conseil des
ministres ensuite on retrouve les décret
du conseil d'état
cette procédure est utilisée si le texte
de loi votée au parlement le précise ou
lorsque le gouvernement décide que le
texte est suffisamment important par
exemple la loi informatique et libertés
prévoit cette procédure pour les décrets
sur les traitements de données à
caractère personnel qui intéresse la
sûreté de l'état
enfin il y aller dès très simple ce sont
les plus fréquents par exemple le décret
dont on parlait tout à l'heure qui
précise la loi evin et d'un décret
simple c'est le mode le plus fréquent
d'exercice du pouvoir réglementaire par
le premier ministre pour résumer un
décret c' est un texte du président de
la république ou du premier ministre qui
met en place une règle et qui est
inférieur aux noix un décret peut être
réglementaire
s'il permet la mise en application des
lois on peut l'appeler décrets
d'application et s'il explicite une
règle spécifique sans rapport avec une
loi on peut parler de décret autonome il
peut aussi être individuel quand il est
utilisé pour nommer un haut
fonctionnaire en fonction de son
importance et il doit être pris en
conseil des ministres en relation avec
le conseil d'état
ou juste par le président le premier
ministre qui est plus fréquent voilà
j'espère que cet épisode vous aura plu
et que vous en connaissez maintenant un
peu plus sur les décrets comme
d'habitude tous les liens qui nous ont
permis de réaliser cette vidéo sans dans
la description
alors n'hésitez pas à les regarder si
vous voulez en savoir plus